اليوم بضل
الفيضانات اللي عم تجتاح ليبيا بلغ عدد
الضفايا حتى الساعه
5200 اسيل للاسف
ولحد الان يحكى عن عشر الاف مفقود
وستين الف
مشرد داخليا هذا الارقام هي معطيات اوليه
وهي بتتغير على الارض تبعا لتقييمات اللي
عم توصلنا من الهلال الاحمر الليبي ووزاره
الداخليه في ليبيا
[موسيقى]
لا يمكن ما جرى اليوم في ليبيا وهذا
الفيضانات المدمره لا يمكن عدله عن الوضع
اللي مرقت في ليبيا والحرب النزاع اللي
امتد نحو عقد من الزمن وبالتالي اليوم
البنى التحتيه هي متهالكه هي من بنى تحتيه
مهيئه لمواجهه هيك كوارث واخطار طبيعيه
السدود هي كانت تتطلب صيانه اذا بنشوف
اليوم حتى الطرق وكل الشبكات الصرف الصحي
والمياه هي نهارت بسرعه كبيره لانها خلال
سنوات الماضيه من النزاع لم يتم الاستثمار
في البنيه التحتيه وتم يعني عدم اطلاعها
بما يجب
بالبدايه عند حدوث اي ازمه او كارثه مثل
ما حدث اليوم في ليبيا يقوم الاتحاد
الدولي لجمعيات الصليب الاحمر والهلال
الاحمر بتخصيص مبلغ مليون فرنك سويسري عبر
صندوق الطوارئ للاستجابه للكوارث اليوم
لانه حجم الكارثه كبير جدا في ليبيا فسارع
الى يعني مباشره
زياده الدعم واطلاق نداء للطوارئ بقيمه 10
مليون
هيدا المبالغ هي لتقدر تساعد الهلال
الاحمر الليبي باستجابه السريعه على الارض
نحن شفنا من الساعات الاولى
الفيضانات فرق الهلال الاحمر الليبي هي
موجوده على الارض عم تقدم الدعم اجلاء
المنكوبين عم تقدم المساعدات الغذائيه
وتقدر تواصل كمان عمليه هي بالاساس البحث
والانقاذ اليوم كمان الاتحاد الدولي هو
دوره تنسيقي لتنسيق عمل كل جمعيات الصليب
الاحمر والهلال الاحمر بالعالم وهو تقديم
الدعم يعني كل جمعيه صليب احمر وهلال احمر
بالعالم بدها تساعد اليوم الهلال الاحمر
الليبي هو التواصل عبرنا لان احنا لن ننسق
هذا الدعم وهلا شاهدنا اليوم الهلال
الاحمر التركي ارسل طائرات مساعده للهلال
الاحمر الليبي موجودين على الارض فرح بحث
وانقاد ومساعدات طبيه لاغاثه الشعب
الليباني بالامس قام المكتب الاقليمي
برئاسه الدكتور حسام الشرقاوي باجراء
اجتماع مع
الهلال الاحمر الليبي ورئيس بعثتها في
ليبيا
المنظمه لجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر وتم
الاتفاق مع كل جمعيات الصليب الاحمر
والهلال الاحمر عدم تارك ليبيا اليوم
منفرده بمواجهه هذه الكارثه وتخصيص كل
الدعم في فرق بتقدر من الهلال والصليب
تقدر تنسى الفرق بحث وانقاذ بيقدروا
يرسموا معدات طبيه وفي منهن بيقدروا
مواد
لمستلزمات الماوى فكل جمعيه عندها تخصصه
امكانيه بتقدر تشيرها لمساعده اليوم
الهلال الاحمر الليبي باستجابته الجمعيات
الوطنيه للصليب الاحمر والهلال الاحمر هن
بيعملوا كعائله واحده مثل ما شفنا بسوريا
او بتركيا كل فرق مختلفه يعني الصليب
الاحمر اللبناني ارسل فرق بحث وانقاذ
تمرين الهلال الاحمر الايراني
السعوديه الهلال الاحمر السعودي
والاماراتي والكويتي امثل
سعادات طبيه وغذاء الى هنالك
الهلال الاحمر
تواصلنا عم بيكون مع السلطات المحليه
مباشره نحن شريكنا على الارض نحن نعمل معه
ومن خلال الهلال الاحمر الليبي وهل بطبيعه
عمل جمعيات الصليب الاحمر والهلال الاحمر
هي دوره تكون هيئات مساعده للسلطات
المحليه على الارض هن من خلال عملهم
بالسابق قدروا يكتبوا هيدي الصفه الحياديه
وهذا الرد على الحاجات الانسانيه للعالم
من دون تمييز وهذا ما خلاهم محطه قبول من
الطرفين
[موسيقى]
كاسحات دوليه جمعيات الصليب الاحمر
والهلال الاحمر ارسلنا بالفعل تحذير الى
جمعيات الهلال الاحمر الليبي لوضعهم في
صوره ان هناك اعصار قادم وعليهم الاستجابه
وبالفعل هم كانوا على هبه استعداد ولكن في
ليبيا الوضع
الاقتصادي بسبب سنوات النزاع يعني الجمعيه
لا تملك الامكانيات الماديه الكافيه
والموارد وحتى الطواقم على الارض هم
بالفعل اذا كانوا مستعدين لهذه الكارثه
ولكن هذه كارثه يعني تفوق قدرات الجمعيه
الوطنيه على التعامل معها ولكن نحن في
عملنا في الاتحاد الدولي هناك نركز على
العمل الاستباقي وهو ما نقوم به هناك خطط
للجمعيات الوطنيه للصليب الاحمر والهلال
الاحمر في المنطقه ندرس ما هي المخاطر
المحتمله وما هي الطرق التي يمكن العمل
عليها للتخفيف من وطاه هذه الكوارث
هو اهم شيء اليوم الماوى اكيد بعد يعني
عمليات البحث والانقاذ مستمره ولكن
بالتوازي معه بدك تلاقي مقوى للناس اللي
شردت واللي ما عاد عندها مكان
اتنام فيه او تبقى فيه ثاني شيء عنا
الخدمات الاسعافات الاوليه والخدمات
الطبيه لانه شفنا مثلا بدي اعطيك على سبيل
المثال درنا المستشفى اللي موجوده هناك ما
قدرت بقى عندك ساعه لتقدر تتحمل عدد هالقد
كبير من المصابين والجرحى والمتضررين
وبالتالي في ضغط كبير على القطاع الصحي
تابعينا بموضوع المياه والصرف الصحي يعني
تدمرت شبكات المياه
وتختار في الصحي وبالتالي هون لم يعد
هناك اليوم التحدي الاساسي انه تقدر تامن
مياه نظيفه وسبكه صارت صحي لما تختلط
المياه ونصير كمان نقوم بكارثه الفيضانات
يصير عنا امراض هي تنقل الالعاب تنتقل عبر
المياه نحن نعرف انه سنوات النزاع خلت انه
ليبيا تكون من بين الدول اللي عندها امن
الغذائي مهدد وفضلا عن الدعم النفسي اليوم
اللي كثير مطلوب لانه الناس عم بيعيشوا
يعني لحظات الرعب الناس اللي عاشوها من
خلال هذه الفيضانات كبيره وراح تلقي
دلالها على الاكيد المدى الطويل والبعيد